[Music]
any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
welcome everybody to this episode of
into the impossible with my guest dr
delilah gates
she is one of the world's experts in
black hole physics and the mysteries of
black holes of which there are many
delilah tell me what is your favorite
most fascinating thing
about black holes oh i think my favorite
thing is that
black holes are the only object we know
about around which
light can travel in circular orbit bound
orbits so
there's this region around a black hole
where if you could sit in it and aim a
light ray just right it would
wind around the black hole and you would
be able to then see the back of your
head
so i think that's pretty fascinating in
particular this implies that there are
actually whenever you view
a black hole there are multiple images
of the emission around it stacked on top
of each other
that's just amazing and who was the
first person to really think about black
holes that they could even you know
possibly be
conceived of if not explored and studied
the first
notion of a black hole actually came
from way back in around 1783
when philosopher john mitchell posited
what if you had a star
that had such strong gravitational pull
that
the escape velocity from its surface was
the speed of light or greater
and today we obviously when we hear that
we think oh he's describing an event
horizon but
of course the idea didn't take off at
the time so everyone was just like okay
what do people really think that dark
matter could be made up of black holes
that's something i get asked about quite
frequently
um probably not i don't i haven't
followed literature in this specific
topic
but um i think the idea more so is
um black holes can be made of ordinary
matter
but certainly if there is dark matter
that you could also have black holes
made of that matter as well so
i don't think at least in general
relativity um as described
by like einstein schwarzschild and kerr
um the black hole it's kind of agnostic
what
what matter made up the black hole so
certainly if you have
um particles that you want to describe
which make up this dark
matter it could of course form black
holes black holes could also be formed
of just the ordinary luminous matter as
well
tell me what is a parametric what is a
schwarzschild metric what does it mean
what is a metric
einstein's equations tell us that
the gravity is really the curvature of
space-time
and so in the equation the mathematical
object that describes the shape of the
space time
is what we call the metric so really the
metric is just the mathematical object
that describes the shape of the space
time
of course einstein's equations are very
general and you can throw in
different shapes and see if they satisfy
the equation and so
if you find a solution that satisfies
the equation then it could describe
gravity in our world there are
particular solutions that describe
different types of black holes that
are often given the names of those who
discovered them so like you mentioned
schwarzschild
the first solution to einstein's
equations which einstein never
expected there to be any solutions that
one could write in closed form
schweinsteil did it very quickly he
described a non-spinning
black hole that had no charge and then
since then
you cannot we've also come to know that
there are solutions that describe black
holes that can be spinning
as well as charged specifically the case
of a non-charged but spinning black hole
this is the one
we think describes the kinds of black
holes that exist in our universe
you are moving from the venerable
harvard university down to princeton
university
where i understand that one of their
predecessors there at princeton uh john
archibald wheeler
coined the term black hole way back when
and he also said something that black
holes have no hair what does that mean
black holes have no hair
the idea that black holes have no hair
really means that regardless of the
matter
that went into making them if they were
formed say from gravitational collapse
that they're only described by a few
parameters
and for the black holes this could be
the mass the rate at which it's rotating
or spinning
um and if it has an electrical charge
and that's it
they really captivate the imagination in
fact they have more paradoxes
associated with them than almost
anything uh one of which being the
famous
information paradox i wonder can you
describe that i know it's not something
you necessarily work on
but people ask me about it all the time
can you can you say is it really
that important this information loss
paradox and what is it first of all
so in physics um even quantum
mechanically
we believe that there's this idea of
determinism which means
if you know what the physics are at one
point of time you can evolve
forward or backwards in time and still
have
enough information to describe the whole
situation the thing about black holes at
least described classically
is that because there's so few details
about them
you can't really say once you've thrown
everything into a black hole collapsed a
black hole
you can't really say anything about what
formed the black hole
further in the 70s hawking came up with
the idea that black holes should
radiate and this radiation is
thermal radiation and as the black hole
radiates
it slowly loses mass but because the
radiation is just purely thermal
that means it carries no information
about the mass that what about the stuff
that went into making the black hole
uh if it completely evaporates and so
this is the information paradox how if a
black hole eventually evaporates
such that there's no even behind the
horizon that we couldn't access but
there's just it's not there anymore
what happened to that information and we
can't reconstruct it from a thermal
distribution
of radiation like hawking originally
described uh there are a couple proposed
resolutions it could be that black holes
actually do have hair
and there's fluctuations along the
surfaces that you would need to use
quantum gravity to describe
it could also be that instead of
completely evaporating
the black holes will start to evaporate
but then they'll leave a remnant
behind and then finally there are those
people who say
maybe we should abandon the information
conservation
altogether another kind of paradoxical
aspect of black holes that i hear
a lot about is the so-called holographic
principle that
somehow black holes because of their
mysterious ability to
encode or encrypt their information
via their surface area what is the
holographic principle what does that
mean
the holographic principle it can really
most readily be thought about it when
you think about entropy so in general
we're used to
describing say the entropy of a bunch of
particles in a box
as having to do with the volume of that
box but for black holes the entropy
isn't described by the volume but just
the surface area of the horizon
so it's really um proportional to the
not the volume that the horizon would
take up um or everything inside the
horizon would take up but just the
just the surface area of the horizon
itself um
and so um this is the holographic
principle that really the
it's the idea that the physics the
entropy
the information is encoded um
on a on a two-dimensional surface as
opposed to in a volumetric way so
it's kind of a hologram um and this is a
you know show for children
but i wanna uh that's friendly for
children it's not necessarily for
children but i want you to describe what
is a naked singularity and keep it clean
delilah please keep it clean
so um despite the scandalous name um
a naked singularity is nothing untoward
but still something
very mysterious and questionable
in its own right so when we think about
black holes we think about this thing
called an event horizon and this event
horizon is this region from which we can
no longer receive information
once anything has passed the event
horizon um it cannot escape back out to
someone or send light even which is the
fastest thing we know
that can move it cannot send any
information via light or anything
back outside the horizon to someone on
the other side and so
in black hole solutions described by
general relativity behind the horizon
we have what's called a singularity and
this is a point where basically
the curvature at least described in
general relativity
appears to blow up and it could be that
there are singularities behind
black hole event horizons or we need to
then move to really using a different
description
of the uh instead of just classical
general relativity
basically as long as you have a horizon
you don't have to think too much about
the singularity but what if you don't
have
an event horizon well if you don't have
an event horizon there would be
just this point that if general
relativity is correct
everything goes to mayhem curvature
blows up and all this stuff uh
crazy stuff happens near as you approach
can you create black holes in the
laboratory
and a particle accelerator is that a
danger is that a reality are they
different than cosmic black holes
so we don't at least in the energies we
have with
like uh the lhc the large hadron
collider we cannot
throw particles together with enough
force to cause tiny black holes
thank goodness so we can't make literal
black holes
that way but i will say there is an
interesting
enterprise of trying to create analog
black holes
these are table top systems using atoms
or fluids
that behave like black holes such that
you could
create little event horizons from which
information in one part of the system
can't go back to a region
on the other side of that horizon and
things like this so there are there is a
whole enterprise of trying to make
tabletop analog black holes uh
that are tiny that we can see here on
earth and have a better handle on such
that we can learn some things
here's a question i asked jen 11 who is
one of my friends and heroes
um and she answered it but i'm not sure
i understood it so i'm going to ask you
what's a black hole made of i i thought
you threw in all this matter they eat it
up
but they're just you know mass been in
charge describe them so
what are they made of ah so
in general in principle in general
relativity they could be made of
anything
realistic black holes though are mostly
made of the kind of matter that that
makes up our universe they
can come from gravitational collapse of
a star in which case they would really
be made of the same stuff the star would
have been made of
so really they could be made of any any
kind of matter we have in the universe
and
and those that result from supernovas
are certainly made
of the stuff that was making up the star
before it blew up
last kind of question oh actually second
to last question just about black holes
is
as cosmic censorship is that related to
this information loss paradox or is that
something different so cosmic censorship
is related to the naked singularity i
mentioned so
like i said if we don't have an event
horizon and we are still using general
relativity
to describe a space time that has a
singularity at the singularity the
curvature will blow up and things like
this and so
even though we can analytically with
math we can describe
this kind of situation the cosmic
censorship tells
conjecture tells us that we suspect it's
just a conjecture so it's not a hard
proof mathematically yet but we
suspect that any configuration that we
could describe with general relativity
that would include a singularity has to
have that singularity
behind an event horizon another question
i get frequently
is is our universe sort of inside a
black hole
could we envision our universe either
emerging from a white hole a black hole
yeah we we could be inside of a very
large black hole it could be
everything in our universe is inside of
the event horizon of a very very very
big black hole that's bigger than our
universe
the reason for this is one of the things
we worry about when we cross a
event horizon you probably have heard
about is spaghettification
as you get close to the black hole the
the change in the amount of gravity on
the side of you closer to the black hole
versus the side farther
from the black hole would be so
different that you would feel like
you're being pulled apart
but it turns out the location of the
event horizon
depends on the size of the black hole
and if the black hole is very big
you can fall past the black hole without
feeling very big tidal forces that would
spaghettify you
so if our whole universe had just was
just
inside of a very big black hole we
wouldn't be seeing any weird
spaghettification happening of our
universe so technically we could be
inside a very big black hole
but it would have to be so big that we
might as well not model ourselves as
being inside of one anyway do you
there's a possibility that black holes
could have been primordial
or can they only form from collapsed
stars or
gravitational uh byproduct of the
evolution of stellar life cycle so this
is not my area of expertise but i
certainly do think
black holes um some subset of black
holes have to be primordial
or are most likely primordial this means
they didn't happen because of a star
that was already a condensed
bit of matter blew up it had
gravitational collapse
and that's what compacted the the matter
tight enough to form an event horizon it
could be that
it wasn't stars form but just everything
of earlier in the universe was kind of a
soup
and it could have been there are
fluctuations in the density of this soup
at different points and some of these
density
very dense regions could have become so
dense they form black holes
and certainly this is probably the case
because
if we look at the black holes at the
center of all our galaxies
all the galaxies invisible universe
there were called supermassive black
holes
and these black holes are just so big it
would take
a lot of sustained
high energy accretion onto them if they
first formed from a star collapse
to then continue eating to get big
enough to be as super massive as they
are
if they hadn't been seeded uh previously
from just um
density fluctuations in in the soup of
matter earlier on in the universe
that reminds me of of the new diet that
i'm going on have you heard of the black
hole diet
delilah you know it sounds like a it
sounds like you can eat anything you
want
you just lose weight because you just
you just eat light oh my goodness this
is a really good one i have to use that
that's an old one that's an old one i
have more if you want um okay now i'm
going to go
into some personal questions would you
like to go nearer black holes of vampire
island
as a tourist only if it was a very big
black hole and i wouldn't get
spaghettified
right because if you get spaghettified
don't forget delilah you passed away
oh no i love them i love puns keep them
coming
like your dad i want to talk about your
dad in a bit but next i want to talk
about academia
and being a graduate student so you just
finished up your newly minted phd
you learn the secret handshake we can do
it now you're going to be what's called
a postdoc
tell me about your academic world line
how did you get to where you are your
parents are both academics
your mother's a a well-known physician
your father is a famous
professor he's uh he's my i guess he's
like kind of like my ultimate boss he's
the president of american physical
society he's the
uh he's a big shot professor at my alma
mater brown university
um so tell me obviously they played a
role but you also took a very different
tack in many ways um tell me about your
academic interest as a young person
and then how you guided your yeah so i
also
i will say have twin brother he is um
a phd student in my biology right now
and so when we were little
um our parents never tried to convince
us
of what career we should take they just
wanted us to
choose something where we would be able
to support ourselves but
even so in our household given just what
they study
there was always a lot of of kind of
math
and and exploration but it happened
through games um so we used to have
fun counting games adding and
subtracting rubber ducks in the tub
or we learned to divide because we were
twins and we want to divide everything
evenly so we would divide
purposefully my father would our mother
would put um
an odd number of breakfast sausages and
so we would have to think about how to
divide them so that everyone who was
eating could have
equal amounts of food um so
from a young age math was always kind of
this fun kind of little game and then we
also used to play with
different things like i remember when we
figured out you could bounce light off
of mirrors
um by just shining flashlights and
playing with the reflective toys we had
in our rooms
and then we uh you know would be so
excited
we would call our parents over and show
them what we figured out
so it started off as just fun and games
um and i always enjoyed it
science and math even in high school um
but in high school i wasn't exactly sure
what i wanted to do
there was i liked music as well i played
clarinet
and then of the kind of science and math
i really enjoyed chemistry
what i enjoyed about chemistry was when
we would talk about the structure of
atoms
and what i learned that they weren't
these the just newtonian model where the
electrons are just
on these toy little bound orbits but
instead had these clouds
people told me to understand that
mathematically what you needed was
quantum mechanics and so it was at the
end of high school that i decided
chemist history uh chemistry physics or
music when i was trying to decide a
major i went with
physics because i figured i could play i
was not an
amazing musician and i could play music
uh habitu as a hobby but i couldn't
do the same with physics so that's kind
of
what i wanted to go into in college and
it as i
took my classes it was really getting
more and more into the world of the
small and the structure
of particles and things like this that
really got my interest and so i really
started
to go down the route of particle physics
and i picked up a double major in math
and then i came to graduate school and i
was kind of trying to figure out what i
wanted to do
and i did a couple rotations so i
knew i wanted to kind of probably high
energy theory thinking about particles
and in fact i do think about light but i
also think now about gravity
um and these giants black holes um
and so what led me to really that was i
took a detour from just high energy
physics and did a couple rotations
one i did in astrophysics and one i did
in cosmology
and it was really these that informed
what i wanted to do within
the high energy theory realm of study
that led me to
what i do now it's a nice marriage
between
thinking about particles and using the
really nitty gritty of the
analytical mathematical to describe
things that are relevant to observation
in these giants of our universe
yeah it's kind of amazing that the
smallest things in the universe
influence the largest things in the
universe and
and conversely you can learn about the
smaller things in the universe
from the largest things did you besides
your parents obviously
one of whom i've had on the show and i
want to have your brother on the show
we've had on
uh i think i've had on you know six or
seven parents of twins i'm a parent of
boy girl twins
i think you're the first uh twin that
i've had on twins are great because you
can do experiments with einstein you
know twin paradox et cetera
but i do want to have on uh your brother
at some point it's cool that you beat
him to the phd all right
you're older than him i forgot by one
minute
right yeah my son uh my twin boy is
older than my
uh twin girl by 15 minutes but a really
uh brilliant man
uh by the name of sylvester james gates
told me uh once he said einstein wasn't
always einstein
and it i i use that line on a man by the
name of barry barish who knows a thing
or two about black holes
and he told me an interesting story
about einstein he said when he went up
to accept his nobel prize in
2017 you have to sign this register this
log book what says i got my nobel prize
from the king of sweden
and and he said i'm kind of curious so
he wanted to see who else signed the
book
so he looked back and he saw richard
feynman wow holy cow there's richard
feynman's name he saw
marie geppert mayor her name is in there
uh marie and he saw
he saw albert einstein and he said um
i never felt like i had impostor
syndrome
more than that moment and i said wow
that's amazing you know
you you probably felt don't feel it
anymore he goes no i feel it even more
than ever
i said you win the nobel prize you still
feel that he said i didn't feel worthy
and and and i said well barry don't you
feel like even albert einstein felt that
way
and and your dad even said that your dad
said you know einstein wasn't always
einstein and if you
make this notion that only einsteins can
do
science then we're gonna eliminate the
next einsteins
and and i think that would be a great
tragedy so i love this idea of self-care
and
and and actually just making time that
we're not what we do
and and despite these kind of notions
that we're just like supposed to be
these
just like we get everything right
everybody's got imposter syndrome that's
the dirty little secret
and we have to we have to recognize that
we are unique
and we all have a gift and we all have
something to give so uh speaking of
of your dad speaking of einstein you
know he wrote a book you know proving
einstein right
uh with it with his co-author kathy and
we had him on the show for that and
had him on also last summer he's a he's
a frequent guest
uh i want to say he's been a huge
influence on me and many scientists
around the world
father's day is coming up i wonder do
you have any uh anything you'd like to
say to him
on this father's day occasion of course
um so we had a
my dad and i had a great time hanging
out during the pandemic so i just want
to say
you know thanks for taking me in during
the pandemic dad it was so much fun to
hang out with you um
happy father's day and i can't wait till
we can get together next
well the uh as newton said the you know
the apple doesn't fall far from the tree
like
the the black holes don't don't orbit
too far around from the event or
i don't know i'm just making that up you
know what they say about you know people
that
that study black holes they have to be
pretty bright uh i'm not that bright so
i couldn't study
uh but but delilah you are a delight and
uh and i wish you such
good luck i hope i can uh see you again
in person
uh we haven't been together in a couple
years since uh since 2019 but i'll
hopefully be in princeton
uh and see you on the east coast uh many
times in the future
i can't wait to see uh where the crew
where your career goes
it's just so exciting to see uh someone
so creative inventive
and working so hard on the forefront of
the most important problems
in science in my opinion so thank you so
much for going into the impossible with
me
uh today delilah have a wonderful rest
of your summer and good luck
and make sure you rejuvenate and
recharge your batteries uh
for what's to come thank you for having
me
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic
if you enjoy this video click here and
come along and arrive to the center of a
black hole
with jen 11 black hole survival guide
and for an experimentalist take you
won't want to miss my interview with
2017 nobel prize winner barry barish
just click here and don't forget to
subscribe to this channel for more great
interviews